[Music]
this is not a test in recent years
there's been much talk of American
schools having been consumed by testing
mania heck I've shared some of these
concerns myself we especially hear these
concerns raised in comparison to
supposed role models like Finland but
how much of an international outlier
really is the US when it comes to
emphasis on testing turns out not so
much a recent OECD analysis shows that
in 2015 83% of us teachers put major
emphasis on classroom tests to monitor
student progress that sounds like a lot
but it wasn't much higher than the OECD
average of 77 percent meanwhile in
science in both oh seven and 2015 US
teachers put less emphasis on tests than
did their OECD counterparts in other
words the US was a bit above the
international norm in math and a bit
lower in science if we think the
international community is a reasonable
benchmark the data suggests that could
surge about over emphasis from testing
have been somewhat overblown do you
think American schools are obsessed with
testing let us know in our poll also let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI